oh my goodness so we're at WWDC and
behind me is the New Vision Pro I can't
believe it like it's here check it out
this is the battery pack that connects
to the headset and this will give you
about two hours but there is a USBC port
on it that will allow you to connect it
to power so you can use it all day
without worry the actual headset
material is very soft and it really does
form to your head the material is super
lightweight but the actual headset does
have some weight to it so I'm not sure
if this is something that I could wear
all day long but a few hours here and
there with some breaks I definitely
could see myself doing that on top of
the Vision Pro are two buttons and this
is the digital Crown which kind of looks
like the digital crown on the Apple
watch what sets this apart from other
devices like it is the eye tracking and
the selection there are no controllers
there's nothing attached to you because
of the sensors here on the bottom you
could have your hands easily resting in
your lap and with a slight pinch motion
of your two fingers that's how you make
a selection the actual viewing
experience when this is on your head is
unbelievable the way that this can
seamlessly take you from one incredible
fully immersed world back into an
augmented reality of you sitting in your
living room is pretty impressive sitting
there and having my entire Apple
ecosystem appear before my eyes in my
space in a virtual reality setting was
unlike anything that I'd really ever
experienced before going into messages
going through photos watching 3D movies
and then getting up off of the couch and
interacting with a dinosaur that just
broke through my wall it really felt
like I was transported to another world
now the price tag of this Vision Pro is
3 500 which is pretty expensive it's not
just a headset apple is calling it a
spatial computer it's not connected to
anything separate everything is
happening inside of the headset it's
powered by a dual chip design that
combines an M2 Chip with a brand new R1
chip and the R1 is basically designed to
handle all this real-time sensor
processing while I don't think that
everyone in the world is going to be
going out and purchasing this headset
right now this is laying the groundwork
for developer offers and content
creators to start making content for
this device having this be announced at
WWDC is also giving developers the
entire freedom to let their imaginations
go wild having the support of Disney
Plus on day one of launch is also really
Incredible Disney has such an amazing
catalog of content plus Star Wars Marvel
and more all of this is leading to
Future devices that could be more cost
effective small better battery life and
who knows what else this my friends is
just the beginning